this was a journey to one of the most
secretive places on earth
we started in one--some on North Korea's
East Coast the fourteen carriages of
this train staffed by soldiers of the
Korean People's Army ahead a four
hundred kilometer journey north into the
mountains government minders escorted us
at all times all the window blinds were
pulled shut and we were ordered not to
open them but we filmed some of this
rarely seen countryside on our way our
train was bound for palm gowri the heart
of North Korea's nuclear weapons program
no journalists had ever seen it Sky News
was the only UK broadcaster invited
eleven hours later traveling through the
night we arrived at JRE a small station
near the test site
we'd been invited to watch plumberry be
destroyed
it was meant to be a gesture of goodwill
ahead of the u.s. North Korean summit
that gesture was spurned by President
Donald Trump the talks canceled at this
point neither we nor the North Koreans
knew that was coming
Hungary the North Koreans have detonated
six nuclear weapons to date since 2006
all of them in tunnels underneath these
mountains we've driven for an hour and a
half to get here we weren't allowed to
take pictures on the way they delete
some of the footage we did take but this
is what we've come here to see this
tunnel the scene at five nuclear weapons
exploded since 2009 now we're about to
go in those five tests include North
Korea's biggest to date only in
September last year thought to be a
massive hydrogen bomb eight times as
powerful as the one that destroyed
Hiroshima inside the tunnel was
ostentatiously wired to explode
this man is the deputy director of North
Korea's nuclear weapons Institute and
holds the rank of general you told us
all we'd see three tunnels collapse the
engines are sealed and the surrounding
buildings destroyed the wind picked up
so we put on our masks protection
against potentially breathing in
particles of radioactive dust it was a
precaution the North Koreans had
confiscated our radiation detecting
equipment then we hiked up to the
purpose-built viewing platform to watch
the first dismantlement of the tunnel
and it's adjoining observation center
the observation tower going up now we
weren't quite sure what to expect you
can feel the waves you can feel the dust
it's a big show for us it's a big show
for the world it's designed to give the
impression that North Korea is serious
about these negotiations officials
immediately declared the tunnel
completely destroyed and invited us to
inspect the debrief this is the wreckage
of the observation center that stood a
bit earlier that's what's left of the
North tunnel where the North Koreans
exploded five nuclear warheads as you
can see there are a lot of journalists
around that point they've invited us to
come and have a look at the wreckage
rather than experts rather than weapons
inspectors to my eye that building that
relatively new was it used as an
observation Center is really hard to
tell the North Korean officers from the
nuclear weapons program kept emphasizing
that these tunnels were still useable
that they could detonate a bomb within
them tomorrow instead they were telling
them into tombs I was told these bags
contain plastic explosives
the destinations came quickly several
North Koreans I spoke to made the same
point why do people say this is just for
show why do they doubt our sincerity
well much of this was for show log
cabins can be rebuilt tunnels can be
excavated entirely new test sites
constructed North Korea has plenty of
mountains but this is a regime that
understands the importance and use of
images both at home and abroad
our presence here was meticulously
filmed for propaganda purposes North
Korea was counting on images like this
to keep Donald Trump kind instead just a
few hours after this moment the US
president canceled the talks
the rocks were still coming down as they
declared poom Gary closed the general
said that the dismantling of the site
was transparent that it attested once
again to the proactive and peace-loving
efforts of North Korea your deputy
director talked about transparency how
can we verify that the tunnels inside
have also been shot you told us we'd
seen it clearly enough with our own eyes
the explosion had come from in the side
the tunnel we did see all three tunnel
entrance is closed but it's impossible
for us to know the extent of the
dismantlement still North Korea opened
its most secret place to the world then
took it apart and then the summit was
canceled who knows how to pick up the
pieces
Tom Cheshire Sky News at punggye-ri
nuclear test site in North Korea